je suis un chasseur de têtes un
véritable orfèvre du boniment allez faut
décrocher un entretien aux ennuis qu'on
passe notre vie au bureau l'oreille
vissée au téléphone le 1er janvier
j'annoncerai le nom du nouveau patron ce
sera la moue boudeuse tu penses que tu
veux moi je trouve que je suis à lyon je
rêve où tu viens de dire que t'étais un
héros
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce petit bidon pour se
remettre au sport moussaillons bonjour
mes chéris la main qui nous arrache et
comment tu pourrais demander à papa
poule j ayew en fait tu n'habites pas
dans cette maison tu viens juste pour y
passer la nuit
tu m'appelles si on décroche ce contrat
pour attendre le mois et vous avez
d'autres pistes de boulot pour moi
non malheureusement mais on est sur le
coup
qu'est-ce qui se passe je suis inquiète
pour ryan je lui ai pris un rendez vous
chez le pédiatre c'est une arête
il se plaint d'être toujours fatigué ces
symptômes ne vous ont pas alerter ce qui
est sûr c'est que ryan ne va pas bien
ap roy 15
vous avez de plus en plus de mal à vous
concentrer sur vos clients je dois
m'arrêter
non je veux diriger ses patins c'est
nous ta famille zane tu regretteras tous
ces moments mais il sera trop tard
[Musique]
vous ne voulez pas de ce poste tout ce
dont j'ai besoin je l'est déjà mais fait
d'auray
[Musique]